shirley woke up screaming louder than
usual this time bae shirley's wife
bolted upright as though someone had
just run a 20 000 volt charge through
her her dirty hand clasped over
shirley's mouth until the awful sound
stopped she whispered baby it was just a
dream just a dream shirley fell into a
terrified silence trying to regulate her
breathing they'd been hiding in an
abandoned apartment block for three days
now waiting for the roads to clear so
they could take the chance and move
forward bay keeping closer to the ground
scuttled over to one of the smashed out
windows she stared down onto the street
30 feet below midnight no stars cars
crashed up against one another from the
initial panic and thank god none of
those things down there she breathed a
sigh of relief and returned to shirley
gathering her up in her arms and giving
her a reassuring squeeze her body was
still trembling what happened in this
one they asked surely exhaled and closed
her eyes we were close now she said
we're so close bae it was the dream that
began this journey the quest for the
last safe place initially bae had
thought it was a fool's errand there
were no safe places in this world
anymore nowhere that the sun or its
terrible monsters hadn't touched but
shirley insisted otherwise she'd seen it
in her dreams a place of almost mythical
wonder a vast and complex facility away
from the light site 19. shirley and bay
grabbed their backpacks and shrugged
them on it was best to set off now get a
few hours of walking under their belts
and find some shelter before the sun
came back up in the meantime all they
needed to do was avoid the monsters
lurking out there it was an interesting
trade-off once upon a time years and
years ago when the sun changed there had
been billions of those things they were
people once until the new light touched
them and turned them into these slimy
abominations there was a time you
couldn't look out your window without
seeing hundreds of them slithering past
you then they started coagulating
becoming these huge mountainous masses
of gloopy melted flesh it was nice that
there were fewer now made them easier to
avoid easier to sneak around but if one
of those things found you you were dead
or more likely you were about to be
something so much worse than dead the
two women trekked down the side of the
road keeping to the shadows even in the
dark they were on the edge of the city
now and it wouldn't be long until they
were in the wilderness pro being away
from a population center meant lower
odds of being attacked by one of those
monsters con fewer places to hide when
the sun came up in the meantime all they
could do was keep walking and home it
was an almost supernatural mixture of
luck and skill that had gotten them this
far they'd known each other for four
years when day broke and everything went
to hell but they'd only been married for
about a month it'd been a hell of a
post-honeymoon wake-up call so many had
been changed in the initial panic and so
many more had been destroyed by what
came after but these two weren't just
anybody in fact it was the specific
combination of skills and knowledge
these two possessed that kept them alive
for this long in the world that came
before bay had been a soldier who done
two tours abroad and seen active combat
multiple times and shirley had been a
doctor rising through the ranks of a
local hospital between them they could
fight for and heal one another despite
everything and in those early years
that's all it had been they were always
moving always avoiding the terrors
outside and the tyranny of the sun
they'd avoided the dangers that had
destroyed so many others but they'd
never dared to hope hope was lofty
impractical it got people killed they'd
only ever tried to survive the immediate
avoidance of death was a practical goal
anything else was just confetti until of
course shirley had started having the
dreams some were just fragments like
sifting through a stack of photographs
in the middle of a deep fog others were
full narratives like movies in her head
viewed in the first person but all of
them were about the same thing
she and bey needed to make it to a place
they called sight 19. something about it
was familiar like a thing she'd heard
years ago perhaps from those strange
broadcasts that were on every tv screen
during the initial chaos oh and of
course there was one more element in the
dream the one thing that made it seem
more like a nightmare in this part of
the dream she was already in site 19 and
walking down a long dark hallway
somewhere far away from the sun there
are a series of heavy reinforced doors
along the wall next to her each one of
them had a number on them advancing as
she got further down the hall zero two
nine zero three zero zero three one zero
three two
that's when she'd hear the voice
that awful terrible
surely
oh
surely
come closer
don't you want to see my face
i'm smiling surely
i'd like for you to see it
she'd reach the door marked zero three
five at which point the door slowly
creaked open even after all the
terrifying things they'd seen in the new
world this somehow paralyzed her with
fear every time it was a kind of dread
she'd never experienced before something
that looked like black water would start
seeping out from the opening door then
footsteps getting closer a shambling
figure would emerge from the open door
it was hard to make it out fully in the
dark but somehow she just intuitively
knew what was coming towards her it had
a stark white face like a mask with
nothing but darkness where the eyes
should be down below the body seemingly
heavily injured and dripping with the
same black water was one she recognized
her own she couldn't move the masked
figure this masked version of her kept
getting closer dripping with more and
more of that black water it was
shaking almost vibrating then she
realized it was laughing
[Music]
see you soon shirley
it said can't wait for you and bae to
visit
and that was when she woke up screaming
somehow despite the grim ending some
part of shirley knew that she and bae
needed to get to site 19 only there
would she be safe and perhaps even find
the answers about how all this horror
had even transpired they were already
risking their lives out here every day
wouldn't it be worth it to find the
truth the duo continued to trudge
through the night it was they think
their lucky stars a relatively
uneventful journey they encountered one
of the flesh beasts on the edge of town
but they were able to hide inside a
nearby bus depot until it slithered on
gibbering incoherent madness after
waiting to make sure it was gone the duo
left the city and ventured out into the
badlands shirley continued to insist
that the legendary psych 19 from her
dreams was definitely close by now bay
looked up to the sky and chimed in i
hope you're right honey for you and me
are fried eggs shirley and bae walked
for another several hours each becoming
more slightly anxious that the sun would
rise before they reached ample cover and
everything they worked for would be
taken away from them the terror
persisted until against all odds a huge
black shape started to emerge along the
horizon the side of it made shirley's
eyes widen in amazement that's it bae
she said site 19 just like it was in my
dreams they passed the chain-link fence
around the perimeter approaching this
large seemingly abandoned building like
it was the lost city of el dorado bay
was astonished she loved shirley of
course and had faith in her beliefs but
something about a place prophesized in a
dream actually being real was honestly
nothing short of a miracle the two of
them approached the fortified front door
and heaved it open together against all
odds they could see light inside the
building they still had power here
nowhere had power anymore maybe this
place really was salvation after all as
the two closed the door behind them they
noticed that the windows all around them
were shuttered it must have been some
precautionary measure against the new
sun smart whoever these people were
they'd thought ahead they'd have some
kind of preparation for all of this so
bae couldn't help but wonder where had
they all gone now as the two ventured
deeper into the building bae unholstered
a handgun that she'd been keeping in her
jacket it was no good against the flesh
monsters but it was a worthwhile
deterrent against other desperate people
out on the road lucky for them she
hadn't needed to fire it yet other than
the power being on somehow the place
seemed abandoned they traveled from room
to room offices filing areas what seemed
like laboratories libraries rest areas
there was no real indication of what
these people whoever they were actually
did around here after searching through
a few different files all written in
almost incomprehensible shorthand in
code shirley at least found a name to
put to these people the scp foundation
was it some kind of charity they
ventured deeper until they found a hall
marked d-class bunks inside they found
bunk beds stacked on top of each other
enough to hold hundreds of people they
wondered aloud whether this was some
kind of secret paramilitary outfit it
was the one thing that might explain
everything they'd seen here today and in
all fairness she was at least partially
right okay ladies hold it right there
shirley and bay turned around to see a
man in an orange jumpsuit standing a few
feet behind them he was carrying an
assault rifle and training it on both of
them he was a tall imposing man and yet
he was shaking they lowered her gun
neither she nor shirley said a word
you're human right he said voice
trembling slightly what shirley replied
just answer the damn question there was
a tense pause where nobody there seemed
to know what might happen to them next
the stranger's finger started curling
around the trigger it was bae who broke
the silence we look human don't we she
said another moment passed the gun
rattled in the stranger's hands he
exhaled and lowered the barrel taking a
more relaxed stance sorry he said can't
be too careful kind of stuff they used
to keep in here it'd give you nightmares
i'm mike by the way he approached
tentatively shaking shirley and bay's
hands just to prove to them that he
wasn't the kind of guy who liked to gun
down random women he asked them whether
they were hungry and when they told them
they hadn't eaten anything but protein
bars in over a week he told them he was
about to show them something incredible
the site 19 break room not long after
that surely bae and mike were all
sitting around enjoying some defrosted
hot pockets at that moment no
three-course meal cooked up by a
five-star chef could ever even compare
as they ate together mike told his story
the people who used to run this place
believe me they were nut jobs sure back
in the day i wasn't such a nice guy me
and some other knuckleheads we needed
the money so we robbed a few places
people got caught in the crossfire next
thing i know i'm on death row and then
these men in white coats they came and
told me i could get a commuted sentence
if i came and took part in some
experiments that's how they got me into
the house of [ __ ] right here if
shirley and bay hadn't lived through the
apocalyptic hell of when daybreaks they
might have not believed mike he told
them about how this scp foundation used
to use humans in experiments subjecting
them to all the monsters they had locked
up down here there was this giant
reptile that couldn't be killed some
freaky statue that would snap your neck
if you stop looking at it but the one
that frightened him the most the one
that haunted his dreams ever since he
got here the mask surely said aloud lost
in thought mike was taken aback how had
she known what he was going to say it
did nothing to reduce his fear when she
told him that she'd been dreaming about
the mask for over a month now stark
white with black water dripping from it
everyone was silent for a moment bay and
mike just stared at shirley equal parts
amazed and frightened mike cleared his
throat and told shirley that in the
years that had passed since day broke
the population of site 19 had slowly
dwindled monsters had escaped the flesh
beasts had slithered in and taken others
over time most of the staff had either
died changed or left all that was left
here was
him and the mask luckily for him he'd
never been directly cross-tested with it
because those who got tested with the
mask never came back sometimes he could
hear it whispering in his dreams trying
to leak itself into his mind drip by
drip poisoning his soul the one saving
grace was that being a mask it couldn't
exactly walk up and tap you on the
shoulder all you needed to do was stay
away from it and you'd be fine the mask
couldn't hurt you on its own the three
of them carried on talking for the last
hours of the morning night had become
day and day had become night it was the
easiest way to survive these days or at
least survive as yourself bane surely
told mike how they'd met in college all
those years ago mike told them the story
of how he managed to survive by hiding
in a broom closet while some gangly
white monstrosity chased down and
slaughtered the rest of his bunkmates
the tiredness took them all again and
they decided to bed down in the d-class
bunks they were more comfortable than
the bed rolls that shirley and bay had
been sleeping on in abandoned buildings
for the last year or so to mike this
place had been a living hell once upon a
time but now for a brief period in this
terrifying new world it could be heaven
surely drifted off to uneasy sleep
trying her best to ignore the whispers
in what only felt like a few moments her
eyes fluttered back open she was in a
new place but one that felt oddly
familiar a long dark hallway bordered on
one side by a series of iron doors she
turned her head slightly eyes still
adjusting to the darkness the number on
the door next to her read
zero two seven further down the hall
shirley saw a dark figure standing tall
shoulders broad and back erect as a
ballet dancer as her vision came back
into focus she saw a shock of orange it
was mike wearing that same orange
jumpsuit he was standing about 10 or 15
feet away staring in the opposite
direction mike surely said operating on
the foggy half logic of a dream he
didn't respond with growing concern she
started stepping closer mike that's when
she noticed something else black water
pooled around mike's feet the sight of
it stopped her in her tracks and froze
the breath in her throat with an almost
audible creak mike turned around a
grinning white mask covered up his face
hello shirley
it said
so lovely to finally meet face to face
eh
i bet you're so glad you ran into me
after all
sleepwalking can be dangerous
shirley screamed and ran in the opposite
direction wasting no time at all she
heard the slow measured footsteps of
mike wearing the mask behind her it was
in no rush it walked like a masked
killer in a horror movie why run
the voice said i've got all day and i
know you can't leave while the sun's up
darling you and your beloved are all
mine it's only a matter of time
somehow despite her being so far ahead
the voice sounded like it was right next
to her ear like it wasn't speaking out
of its mouth it was just talking
directly into her brain with every
syllable her mind started to slow like
the mask's voice was tar seeping in
between the gears soon enough her legs
stopped working shirley was frozen in
place hearing the footsteps of the
masked mic behind her her brain was
flooded with dark thoughts death pain
torture grief the final smothering of
all hopes and happiness there was really
nothing like it like every nightmare
she'd ever experienced being collected
into one terrible elixir and poured onto
her mind so this was what that horrible
mask could do soon enough the masked mic
had passed her and turned to look
directly at her face there was an awful
smell like chemicals and burning flesh
she turned her gaze downwards seeing
that it looked like mike's body was
somehow melting away from all that black
water it was like acid mike was a weak
host the mask said as if it was replying
to her thoughts he won't last much
longer but that's fine i'm looking
forward to taking you for a whirl dear
shirley
and when your hands are mine
you can only imagine the terrible things
i'm going to do to your beloved bae with
them
surely with all her willpower was able
to move her mouth enough to force out
the words don't you dare touch her the
monster laughed just like it always did
in her dream
[Laughter]
that's not your choice to make anymore
it's sad the masked reached for her with
mike's melting fingers fizzling away
with all that black slime getting so
close to caressing her tender cheek all
that awful silence was only broken by
the sound of a soft clicking behind it
then a gunshot passing through the back
of its stolen head the mass turned more
shock than anything to see bae standing
there wielding mike's old assault rifle
and aiming it with deadly accuracy
before the mass could breathe another
poisonous word bay opened fire releasing
a volley of bullets into the last of its
melting body as it staggered back into
the darkened hallway shirley watched an
astonishment as the creature fell mike's
body splattering into a puddle and
sending the mask itself skittling down
the hallway maybe it was just a trick of
the mind but she could swear the mask
was frowning now
not smiling bay breathed a sigh of
relief and said i'm thinking it's
probably better if this place stays
abandoned
shirley who hadn't quite regained her
speech just yet just smiled nodded and
embraced bay they shared a kiss just
happy to still be together and alive
despite it all come nightfall they left
again in search of another place the
possessive mask remained there laying on
the floor of some anonymous site 19
hallway just waiting for some unlucky
weak-minded survivor to wander in and
try it on now go check out scp-035 the
possessive mask and when day breaks
scp-096
to learn more about today's terrifying
anomalies